strange about kind of going back you
know you mentioned sex pistols then I
met Steve we played with the Sex Pistols
early 1976 down in Bridgend in South
Wales only was a teenager face yeah when
he was a teenager I was quite surprised
that there was a bit of the burgeoning
punk scene down there even before there
was really one in London so that was not
shocking but an eye-opener and I got
chatting to Steven he said but where are
you playing next and the next day we had
a gig in burton-on-trent in the Midlands
and anyway we got up light and drove up
there and got there for sound check he
was already waiting in the car park park
he'd hitchhiked his way up there and
he'd seen something different and he was
looking for a way out of the kind of a
grayness for the valleys down there
there's something different that he was
a punk before he was in you remember but
it was a punk it was a guy who wanted to
do something as our crowd was he was a
bit younger than me and my friends with
him and we kept in contact and actually
come up to London I put him up in my
flat hips on the floor so your friends
despite the fact that some say that the
formation of visage at the end of your
own band which hits yeah kind of older
that you know things of a built-in shelf
life I had a band after this exhibition
is called the rich kids and so the guys
rusty egan the drummer media who were in
a band they teamed up the Steve and
decide projects between bazaars and it
took off and whatwhat about the music
for you it's well it's not as Howard as
Punk your previous styles talking from
the on the screen there he said as much
to sign himself I like Steve he was an
instigator it was an interesting crowd
around them people all went on to do
some things he provided a scene and it's
very kind of hard to do that I don't
think it was a fantastic singer or
songwriter or no kind of good enough but
he had something a bit more you know you
could go back to somebody like Alan
Freed who championed order early rock
Rimmel records and with the first person
to start playing in the States
Steve sort of had a role write that a
little bit he helped to popularize cross
work the normal Bryce Jones that stuff
and of course New Romantics as well
which although your mind to come out
about yeah and as again you know your
other contributor said the pump thing
was very back of mine and any books and
currents of people's life I mean you use
the word instigator earlier on one of
the things that the movement did was it
brought in the drogyny and an important
a gay people into the sort of frontline
and politics and a off of rock music
which was very different from the sort
of punk era yeah but some of us not
think that some people in the punk
movement rolled with that as well you
know so but you didn't sort of celebrate
it by dressing out and well no that's
kind of true but I think it was an
actual extinction that I think the news
it was slightly like wait but I think
the scene it created was fun so how
would you summarize his legacy then I
think it's bit too early to summarizes
legacy but I think all around the world
is little people in little towns who
live kind of gray lives and he brought
some color to them and I think he's good
for that